on a tellement entendu parler des
républicains comme d'une famille
politique qui allait se déchirer un tas
de la question de savoir s'il fallait
rejoindre ou non emmanuel macron khalil
al shihri non adhérentes et c'est que
les républicains sont dans leur immense
majorité certains que leur place est
d'être dans l'opposition à emmanuel
macron non pas pour le plaisir de
l'opposition n'y a aucune espèce de
jubilation à critiquer pour critiquer
mais parce que d'abord nous connaissons
emmanuel macron nous connaissons son
bilan et nous savons que nous ne pouvons
pas soutenir l'action qu'il a menée quoi
qu'ils décrivent aujourd'hui son mandat
futur comme le mandat d'un président
nouveau élu par un peuple nouveau nous
nous avons de la mémoire et nous croyons
au temps long et nous savons que nous ne
pouvons pas faire confiance à quelqu'un
sur la base de l'action qui a été menée
au cours des cinq dernières années qui
n'est en rien meilleure que celle de
françois hollande avant lui en rien
le deuxième point c'est qu'au fond nous
avons la certitude que notre
responsabilité démocratique c'est
d'incarner une alternative et c'est ça
dans les français ont le plus besoin et
cette alternative ne la connaissons nous
savons ce que nous avons à faire